Çeviri: Ahmet Kurnaz
Gözden geçirme: Sancak Gülgen
Görüyorsan, duyuyorsan, sorumlusun
yaşam felsefem bu
Bir gün, hayatımı değiştiren insanlardan biriyle karşılaştım
Ercan
Balat'ta bir çay ocağında oturuyorum
Yanıma geldi, "bana bir çay ısmarlasana" dedi.
Bir çay söyledim
"Ercan abi ne iş yaparsın?" dedim.
"Pantolon ve sandalye yapıyorum" dedi.
Nasıl yapıyorsun dedim
"Bakış açısıyla atom bombasını birleştiriyorum,
... pantolon ve sandalye oluyor dedi."
İyiymiş, dedim.
Peki, "masa ve ceket yapamıyor musun?"
"Onun henüz yöntemini bulamadım" dedi.
Mesela dedim, bakış açısıyla nötron bombasını
birleştirsen olmaz mı?
"Sen manyak mısın?" dedi.
Bu durumda manyak olan ben oluyorum.
Sonra, durdu, durdu, durdu.
"Sevmek lazım" dedi.
"... Çok fazla sevmek lazım
Sadece kuşu, böceği, çiçeği, insanı değil
... yaratılan her şeyi, taşı toprağı da sevmek lazım."
Bunun için de mangal gibi yürek lazım
O yürek de Ercan'da var
O yüzden Ercan deli
Otobüslere alamıyorlar
Üstümüz başımız pis ya!
1960'lı yıllarda İstanbul'da Yeniköy'de bir yalıda doğdum
Şanslı görünen bir çocuktum
Annem, babam iyi eğitim almıştı
Ben de iyi eğitim aldım
Ama yaşamın en başında dikkatimi çeken şey
adaletsizlik ve eşitsizlikti.
Annem şiddet gören bir kadındı
çevremdeki bütün kadınlar şiddet görüyorlardı.
Bu beni çok rahatsız ediyordu
çünkü çevremdeki bütün kadınları çok seviyordum.
Allah'ın erkek olduğunu (baba)
ve kadınları aşağıladığını düşündüm.
Tanrı'yı reddettim.
Yolculuğum devam etti
Etiler Lisesi'ne girdim.
O eşitsizlik ve adaletsizlik duygusu
beni yasadışı, sol, anarşist ve terörist bir örgütte
militan yapmaya itti.
O sırada çok üzüldüğüm olaylardan biri
üç tane arkadaşım üniversite sınav harcı olmadığı için
sınavlara giremediler.
Benden çok başarılıydılar.
Biz ne yapıyoruz? 12 Eylül yılları henüz gelmemiş.
Kalp ilacı yok piyasada. Depoyu basıyoruz
kalp ilacını halka dağıtıyoruz.
Sana yağı deposunu basıyoruz, insanlara dağıtıyoruz.
Camilerden ampul çalıyoruz, minarelerden,
insanlara dağıtıyoruz.
Otuz tane kamyon kaçırdım, gıda kamyonu
Şoförler tanıyordu. Silahı uzatırdık,
"Tamam, ağabey" derlerdi.
Çağlayan'da (aşağıya). Çeliktepe'de. Ümraniye'de
insanlar sıraya girerdi ve halka dağıtırdık.
Oysa eşitlik kavramının
örgütlerin içinde de olmadığını
bir süre sonra öğrendim.
Yakalandım, Diyarbakır cezaevine girdim.
'82 - 84' arası iki yıl orada yattım
işkenceler falan. Çıktım, geldim,
okulumu bitirdim.
Ailemin bana verdiği temel duygu;
ne olursa olsun, paran olmalı.
Çok paran olmalı, daha çok paran olmalı.
Paran yoksa, adam değilsin.
İstediğin kadar oku,
bunu paraya çevirememişsen hiçbir işe yaramaz.
Çevrendeki adamlar boştur,
yalnızlık içinde ölür geberir gidersin.
Ufak işler, ufak ihaleler,
büyük ortaklıklar derken,
26 yaşıma geldiğimde ilk milyon dolarımı
kazanmıştım ama paraya dokunamıyordum.
Çünkü ya para biterse,
ya aç kalırsam, ya yalnız kalırsam…
Bu duygular içinde para biriktirmeye devam ediyorum.
Bir yandan korkudan sürekli içiyorum,
alkol ve uyuşturucu.
Öyle duvarlar örmüşüm ki etrafıma,
dışarı bakmaya cesaretim bile yok.
Ama temel duygum boğuluyorum,
yaşayamıyorum. Yaşayamıyorum.
İçmek zorundayım.
Sabah kalktığımda
bir ufak vodka içmek zorundayım.
Ondan sonra dışarıya çıkıyorum,
yine içmeye devam ediyorum.
28 yaşımda bir sürü param var dokunamadığım.
"Yüzleşmem gerekiyor," dedim.
Dibimi bulmam gerekiyor.
Parasız kalırsam ne oluyor görelim.
Evi terk ettim,
Rumelihisarı'nda bir tekneye yerleştim.
Sonra sokaklarda yaşamaya başladım
ve 3,5 sene sokaklarda yaşadım.
Şunu gördüm; aç kalmıyorsun.
Hangi lokantaya giderseniz gidin,
en lüksünden çorbacısına kadar,
"Karnım aç, param yok,"
dediğinizde sizin karnınızı doyuruyorlar.
Birinden para istediğinizde,
"İçki alacağım, 5 liraya ihtiyacım var,"
10 lira veriyorlar, 20 lira veriyorlar,
50 lira veriyorlar.
3,5 sene hiç para harcamadan yaşadım.
Sonra kardeşlerim beni yakaladı.
Arada bir yakalıyorlardı,
hamama falan götürüyorlardı.
Hastaneye götürdüler.
İşte tomografiler, bilmem neler,
tahliller falan filan; sirozmuşum.
İçkiyi sigarayı bırakmazsam,
1 yıl kadar ömrüm varmış, ölecekmişim.
Ben de gittim Aşiyan mezarlığında
bir mezar satın aldım.
Bu! Üst görüntüsünü de görelim.
Mezarın içine girdim
yaptırdım o mezarı o şekilde, beton halde
Mezarın içine girdim ve
8,5 ay o mezarlıktan hiç aşağı inmedim.
Sadece içtim, okudum ve düşündüm.
Hiç aç kalmadım, hiç içkisiz kalmadım.
Kim getirdi bilmiyorum.
Karda tipide, köpekler kuşlar bile yokken
benim içkim geldi.
Radikal gazetesi okuyordum.
Her gün o Radikal gazetesi geldi, o tepede.
Kitaplarım geldi.
Sadece felsefe ve edebiyat okurdum.
Yemeğim geldi. Hic aç kalmadım.
Ateist olarak girdiğim mezarlıktan,
Sufi olarak çıktım.
Mezarlık boyunca düşündüm,
"Nedir bu korku ya?"
Evler, bilmem neler, malikâneler.
Bir yalıda doğduk.
Bir metrekarede yatıyoruz.
Yükseklik 85 santim, en 90 santim, derinlik 1.95.
İçinde bir sünger yatak var,
yatıyorsun, yaşıyorsun.
Çok tipi yağdığında, yağmur yağdığında,
önüne bir naylon örtüyorsun, bitti!
Manzara dehşet. Dehşet!
Peki, nedir bu korkunun sebebi?
Bir gün bir çöp tenekesinde yatıyorum,
yani çöp tenekesi kulübesinde.
Yeniköy'de. Polisler geldiler,
apar topar beni aldılar.
Çöp tenekesinin sahibi Vehbi Koç'muş,
orada yatılamıyormuş.
Yine bir gün bir tekneyi çektim
Sabancı'nın Atlı Köşk'ünün önüne, kaldırımda.
Aylardır orada yatıyorum.
Sabahleyin Sakıp Sabancı
yürüyüşe çıkmıs korumalarıyla.
Burun buruna geldik. Ben de tekneden çıkıyorum.
Hemen topladı kendini. "Ya ne güzel," dedi,
"benim evim 200 metre denize,
seninki 1 metre."
Dedim ki, "Hoca, bırak laf ebeliğini.
Ben senin evinde yaşarım. Sen burada yaşayabiliyor musun?"
Güldü. "O zaman 200 lira ver," dedim.
Vehbi Koç'tan da bir 10.000 dolar almıştım.
Onu da dışarda anlatırım.
Şimdi… Peki, korkular, korkular, korkular, korkular.
Aşiyan mezarlığına girdiğimde
cebimde 65 lira para vardı.
65 bin lira, eski para.
Çıktığımda yine 65 lira vardı.
Hiç para harcamadım.
İçki geldi, sigara geldi, yemek geldi,
kitap geldi, gazete geldi.
Eh, peki korkular ne?
Niye yaşıyorum ben bunları ya?
Şunu anladım;
bu coğrafyada açlıktan ölmene olanak yok.
Doyuruyorlar seni.
Şimdi dışarda hanginizde ben
1 lira, 2 lira istesem,
burada bin kişi olsa,
yarınızdan birer lira alsam,
500 lirayı cebime koyar ve giderim.
Bu ülkede böyle yaşanıyor.
Bu coğrafyada böyle yaşayan,
bu seçimi yapan binlerce insan var.
Korkuları mezara gömdüm ve mezardan çıktım.
Şunu anladım; benim önümde tek bir engel var.
Ben.
Kendimi kaldırdığımda, korkularımı kaldırdığımda,
bütün evren benim.
Sınırlar yok. Ben belirliyorum.
Gittim Bakırköy akıl hastanesine yattım.
Son kez.
Alkol ve maddi tedavisini gördüm. Çıktım.
"Yaşam benim artık.
Kendi kurallarıma göre oynayacağım," dedim.
Bir ton para var.
Bir işe girdim, battım.
Bir daha girdim, battım.
Bir daha girdim, battım, çıktım.
18 kere battım, çıktım.
Para dijital bir rakam.
Beni hiç ilgilendirmiyor.
Eğlendim, çok eğlendim.
İnsanları izliyorum.
İhalelerde iş yaparken, kaygılarını, korkularını.
Çok eğlenceli. Hala izlerim.
O kadar basit şeylerden korkuyorlar ki…
Sonra yeterince eğlendiğime karar verip,
Balat'a gittim.
Balat İstanbul'un en fakir,
en fanatik, en okumamış,
en en en - kötü anlamda - semtlerinden biri.
Orada Yaşar ağabey ile tanıştım.
Yaşar ağabey 42 yaşında.
Ama 5 yaşında bir çocuk zekasına sahip.
Dünya tatlısı bir insan.
Odunla kovalıyorlar çay istediği zaman.
Yaşar ağabeye sahip çıktım.
Onunla birlikte çay içiyoruz, yemek yiyoruz.
Derken, Ercan geldi.
"Sevmek lazım" dedi. "Çok sevmek lazım."
Ben de Deliler Kahvesi'ni kurdum.
İki arkadaşımı daha yanıma aldım.
Derviş Baba Deliler Abdallar Meczuplar ve Aşıklar Kahvehanesi.
Mahallenin 18 delisini
Mahallenin 18 delisini topluyoruz
yakaladığımız yerde,
her hafta düzenli hamama götürüyoruz.
Üstlerindeki başlarındaki her şey atılıyor,
yeni baştan giydiriliyorlar ve
günde 3 öğün yemek orada.
Derviş Baba'da ayrıca
"karnım aç, param yok," dediğinde,
herkese serbest.
Bütün menü serbest.
Sadece onu yiyebilirsin, bunu yiyebilirsin değil.
Sonra… Aralık ayı, kar atıştırıyor,
parkta yatan aileleri gördük.
33 aile, Sulukule yıkımından,
kadın, çoluk çocuk, anne baba, parkta yatıyorlar.
Bir kampanya başlattık.
33 aileyi evlere aldık.
Balat'ta ev kiraları 300 lirayla 400 lira arasında değişiyor.
Ve onlara gıda göndermeye başladık haftalık.
Kahvehanedeki sedirlerin içinde saklıyoruz,
müşteriler geliyor, "Ne bu?" diyor.
"İşte bunun için götürüyoruz, gönderiyoruz.
Onlar geliyorlar alıyorlar."
Onlar yardım etmeye başladı.
Onlar gıda almaya başladı.
Bizim ufacık kahvehane
kocaman bir organizasyona dönüşmeye başladı.
Biri geldi, adımızı duymuş.
Bacağı yok, protez bacak istiyor.
Hemen aradık sorduk,
bilmem ne ilişkileri kullandık yaptırdık.
Akülü araba. Aldık.
Şu çocuk - gözlüklü - ağlıyor hüngür hüngür.
Bütün derdi o bir liralık gözlük.
Bir lira. Onu mutlu ediyor.
Ötekinin ayakkabısı yok.
Suriye'den öyle gelmiş.
Bir ayakkabı Balat'ta 20 lira, bir bot.
Bugün 423 aileye,
bu ay itibariyle - bu ayki rakam -
düzenli her ay gıda götürüyoruz.
Öyle şirketlerin Ramazan kolileri değil,
adam gibi.
Gıda mühendisleri çıkarttı;
eti, sütü, yumurtası, beyaz peyniri, ne gerekiyorsa.
Ne kadar gerekiyorsa, o gidiyor.
150 civarında çocuğa burs veriyoruz.
Burs almak için bir koşul var;
her ay beş kitap okuyacak yaşına göre,
özetini çıkartacak, anlatacak.
Dini kitap yasak, siyasi kitap yasak.
Balat'taki çocuklara soruyoruz;
"Etiler neresi?"
"Orada fahişeler yaşar,
bir de pezevenkleri yaşar."
İyi. "Bağdat Caddesi?"
"Orada Yahudiler yaşar, bu ülkenin altını oyarlar."
"Kimdir Yahudiler?"
Şeytan gibi bir şeyler tanımlıyorlar.
Bağdat Caddesi turları başlattık. Etiler turları.
Oradaki arkadaşlarımızın evine götürüyoruz,
onların çocuklarıyla yemek yiyorlar.
Ve sonra mutlaka 2 sanat galerisine gidiyorlar.
Bugüne kadar 220 aileyi ev sahibi yaptık,
evlere soktuk.
Bayramlarda çocukları bayram alışverişine götürüyoruz.
Onun dışında zaten hep giydiriyoruz
ama bu çocukların özellikleri;
ilk kez bir mağazaya gidiyorlar
ve ilk kez sıfır bir şey giyiyorlar.
İlk kez. Bilmiyorlar.
Genelde girdiklerinde atıyorlar pantolonları.
İnanamıyorlar çünkü.
Şimdi Suriyeliler geldi.
Suriyeliler için bir dershane açtık.
Şu ana kadar 150 çocuğu mezun ettik.
Kalacaklar galiba.
Hiç olmazsa dilimizi öğrensinler,
iletişim kurabilelim.
Kırk tane öğretmenim var;
tamamı gönüllü.
Ben dahil herkes gönüllü.
Bu işte zaten deniz feneri olmamak için,
ya da başka bir sey,
ya gönlünü koyarsın, ya da koymazsın.
Yani, sevmek lazım.
Deli gibi sevmek lazım.
Çok sevmek lazım.
Ve her zaman önünde iki seçenek vardır;
görüyorsan, duyuyorsan, sorumlusun.
Ve iki seçeneğin vardır;
ya sırtını döner gidersin,
"ben zaten yardım yapıyorum başkalarına," dersin.
Ya da adam olursun, insan olursun,
bir ucundan da sen tutarsın.
Teşekkürler.